arjun opened up a savings account last
year and put an initial sum in it
let m of t denote the account balance m
measured in dollars t days since it was
opened
what does the statement m of 30
minus m of 0
equaling a hundred means so before i
even look at the choices let's think of
it this means when you input t equals 30
into your function you're going to get m
of 30. so let me make that clear so if
you say t
is equal to 30 you input
that into your function m
you are going to get you are going to
get m
of 30. so one way to think about it is
this is the account balance
30 days since it was open this is when t
is equal to 30. this is the account
balance after 30 days so let me write
that down balance
balance after
30 days
now by the same logic this right over
here this is when we put t when we set t
equals zero this is the bounds after
zero days or you could say this is the
initial balance
initial
initial balance so what they're doing
they're taking our balance after 30 days
and from that they're subtracting the
initial balance and they're saying that
that's equal 100 equal to 100. so
there's a couple of ways you can
interpret this and i haven't even looked
at these choices yet we'll see if any of
these match up you could say that your
balance after 30 days is a hundred
dollars more than the initial balance or
another way to think about it is you've
added a hundred dollars in the first 30
days those are both legitimate ways to
think about it now let's see which of
these choices are
consistent with that
30 days after it was opened the balance
of arjun's account was equal to a
hundred
no that's not what that's saying this
statement right over here that the
balance 30 days after opening
this statement right over here this
would be equivalent
this is equivalent to saying that m
of 30 this is the balance after 30 30
days after it was open is equal to 100.
that's not what they tell us here they
tell us that the difference between the
balance after 30 days and the initial
bounce that that is a hundred so we can
rule that one out
arjun had the initial amount of money in
his account 30 days after he opened it
so if he had the same amount if he had
the initial amount let me write this
down so had the initial amount of money
the admission the initial amount of
money is m
of zero
so they're saying he had the initial
amount of money in his account 30 days
after he opened it well the amount that
he has in his account 30 days after he
opened it is m of 30. so if these are
the same amounts of money then this in
order to be consistent with this you
would have had an equation like this m
of zero the initial amount is equal to
the amount after 30 days that's not what
they told us over here so we can rule
that out
and then finally we have the choice
arjun made a profit over of a hundred
dollars over the first 30 days since the
account was opened
and that seems reasonable that his
balance is a hundred dollars higher the
difference between if you take his
initial balance and subtract it from his
balance after 30 days it's a hundred
that this right over here is a hundred
higher than his initial balance so it
makes sense that maybe he got that
profit i don't know it's an interest or
something else that he got in his bank
account over the first 30 days